there was an announcement from the from
the mcauliffe uh campaign the
announcement was that uh the the vote in
fairfax county was going to be delayed
the count oh they there was a problem
with the count they had to pause the
account we had flashbacks to 2020. oh
yeah you're gonna pause it until three
in the morning you're gonna find
truckloads full of ballots right and in
in mcauliffe's defense
it it is very difficult
to figure out how many ballots to stuff
into the ballot box
before you know what the numbers are in
the other counties so in his defense you
know he had to wait a little while it
didn't matter and by the way terry
mcauliffe never concedes okay don't
don't forget that terry mcauliffe
during this very campaign in the year of
our lord 2021
refused to admit that george w bush won
the 2000 presidential election
in this very campaign in the year of our
lord 2021
terry mcauliffe refused to acknowledge
that stacey abrams legitimately lost the
2018 uh georgia gubernatorial election
that's what happened so what did this
election come down to this election came
down to one
moment
that was repeated over and over
mcauliffe kept making the same mistake
the moment came
during
a uh
a question for mcauliffe on the quest on
the issue of education terry mcauliffe
said parents need to butt out
the parents had to write
to veto bills veto books glenn not to be
knowledge about it also take them off
the shelves and i'm not going to let
parents come into schools and actually
take votes out make their own decision
you vetoed it so
yeah my parents stop the bill that i
don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach but i
don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach now don't
forget
education is not just about your reading
writing and arithmetic education broadly
is
how a child is raised right education is
not just about technical knowledge not
just about book learning it's about
moral knowledge it's about socialization
it's about how to be a citizen
and so if your kid is going to a school
for 12 years 13 years with kindergarten
now what 14 15 years with the pre-k now
what 16 17 18 19 years with college
which is being pushed for everybody or
more
then
what the terry mcauliffe is saying here
is you have no right to raise your kid
some government employee has the right
to raise your kid
but you do not have the right to raise
your kid i think
on this issue of education
the race came down to three things
it came down to chris ruffo chris ruffo
is the uh scholar at the manhattan
institute in city journal who has been
exposing critical race theory and sort
of setting the stage
for critical race theory specifically
and the kind of radical racial and
sexual ideologies being taught in
schools i don't think this race would
have turned out the way it did without
chris ruffo doing that
then there was the next level and
you know i can say it without any pride
or false modesty because though this
involved friends of mine
it wasn't it wasn't me directly okay
it comes down to the sweet baby gang
okay and and my colleague matt walsh
going and pulling his stunt at the
school board in virginia
and exposing the radical it's not just
crt it's crt it's the crazy transgender
stuff it's the masking it's the making
the kids get the jab it's all of that
okay but it is kind of about the kids it
is kind of about the future and then
beyond that even more specifically than
chris or matt
it was this story
from luke rosiak the the daily wire
investigative journalist
a specific news story about a rape of a
young girl in a virginia school
that was covered up by that school
district because the school district
didn't want to have to answer for their
insane transgender bathroom policy
okay and that
that story to me is the pivotal story
because
all the rest is reacting to other things
that is that that were going on
the the rosiac story
the the transgender bathroom story
was a news story
that was not coming out
okay the new york times wasn't going to
cover it the washington post wasn't
going to cover it
and usually what happens because
investigative journalism is expensive is
the left-wing outlets
waste the money spend the money that
they're never going to make back
breaking the news and then conservative
outlets have to take their biased
accounts of those stories and then try
to parse that fact from fiction and so
we're always on the defensive and the
stories that they don't want to cover
they just don't get covered
so the fact that dw decided to invest in
real investigative journalism
i think played a decisive role here
there were other things as well the
coveted lockdowns people didn't like it
that went on and on and on the forced
vaccine mandates people didn't like it
the fact that gas is going through the
roof the fact that our grocery stores
are closed i don't think it's simple
enough to say that the race was all
about education but just as
the tea party was about taxes debt
government spending just as that was the
last even somewhat grassroots movement
on the right
so too this is the this is the latest
grassroots movement on the right that
i've seen
call it the crt party
you know the tea party was all about
money and it was all about
financial and fiscal issues this one is
about deeper issues cultural issues your
family who has the right to raise your
kids what the future of the country
looks like
i'm so glad that you liked that clip i
liked that clip too darn it
if you want more of those clips you can
ring the bell subscribe you will i hope
get notifications probably knowing these
people you probably won't but
you'll be more likely to get
notifications and you can go over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play myspace xanga
live journal wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show we will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]